Here the solutions are negative 5 plus or minus 2 root 6 all divided by 3.
Great algebra skills if you got this one correct. You may have also entered
this as your answer. This is correct as well. You would of divided 3 into the
first term and 3 in the second term. Since there's no common factors we just
list these two terms as fractions. With a plus or minus symbol in between. To
start this problem, we take the square root of both sides of our equation. And
we indicate the plus or minus sign for this root. So we'll have 3x plus 5 on
the left. And positive or negative root 24 on the right. Next, we want to
isolate this 3x by subtracting 5 from both sides. We'll get 3x equals negative
5, plus or minus root 24. And finally, to solve for X, we divide both sides by
the coefficient 3. This leaves us with 1x equal to negative 5 plus or minus
root 24, all divided by 3. We want to look to see if we can simplify any
radicals, if possible. The square root of 24 is simplifies to 2 times root 6.
So we can replace this here in our final answer.